austin green a apresentação do que agora
vai ter que mostrar o aluno meu trabalho
e vou começar por aquilo que pode
abordar como é costume não há equipas e
canelas nada dessas coisas
acham que eu vou mostrar um bocadinho
daquilo que eu faço
venho de uma família um photoshoot regra
minha mãe também é artista plástica seja
com podem prover a câmera foi demasiado
cedo pra mim
com a ressalva de que os 150 espera que
possa reservar água possa ser mais nunca
falei nada disso eu trago algumas
histórias do meu trabalho
vamos mostrar três histórias muito
simples muito simbólica sobre o que eu
faço diariamente notícias e também que
seu projeto comentários têm feito ao
longo dos anos o primeiro trabalho com
marketing conduzir acompanhados canto e
eu vou baixar impostos você não ter mais
importante é que nosso embaixador e ao
expresso o senhor josé oliveira formato
70 anos está 110 anos à espera de uma
nova bolsa das finanças para poder
continuar a sua vida limitada
costumo me soltar
eu e na briga e violência doméstica
o seu mérito o seu marido era ex militar
continua a apresentar que esse tipo de
alimento
não sou nada essa barbaridade ontem 58 a
formado e com uma pensão 280 euros
como imaginar quem consegue ver com 30
cadeiras as suas histórias que eu passo
para para o jornal de alimento
são histórias que de outra forma não
teria uma visibilidade
eu não tenho voz fixa nosso livro
realmente precisar vou chamar um crime
também foi total e estamos das tropas
internacionais que eu fiz a crise
migratória mas estamos a falar aqui
sobre não queria nunca história de
esperança histórias de vida
essas pessoas viajem muitas vezes
durante dias em alto mar para se poderem
salvar o que está acontecendo a deus que
vá mesmo quando a situação criou em
junho de 2016 a não cair o acerto e como
podem ver estas pessoas chegou ao seu
limite para o governo
quando cheguei lá para mim como eu dar
um carrinho de venda que contava com
tarde será de graça total a ser o fim do
mundo mas não na verdade as pessoas têm
muitas empresas têm muitas alianças
pensar em dias melhores
a verdade é que só querem voltar às suas
casas nos países faz o controle e
voltarem a viver o evangelho ensina
muita coisa em si não é não desistir
ensinou também no momento
neste momento em que eu vejo esta
criança hipotermia
a segunda marca não fotografar
larguei tudo obrigado a inúteis no
banheiro e 12 crianças excluídas não é
uma questão de beleza é uma questão de
necessidade como está sempre presente
mas as pessoas menores de 16 anos e seu
filho
eu tenho medo as pessoas vivem no limite
como já expliquei mas não desistem por
nove presos fazer para as crianças
para tentar se livrar no hotel
vocês só verão cannes em maio tem que
estar sempre a falar das que uma seca de
coleta em todo o mundo
mais uma vez as provas
isto é o que acontece diariamente sem
maioría ficamos com associados ao lado
do campeão em duas nações unidas por seu
baixo em 34 dias em automático e não
dinheiro rocha com cerca de 60 pessoas
faz viram um barco vai ser exatamente
igual ao que nunca estou na verdade é
que ter sorriso estudo
arranjam sempre maneira de se distraírem
ano porém as crianças a brincar até
tranquilo foram improvisados na igreja
fará as crianças conseguiram ser
extraído o petróleo está a crescer o que
implica que os vários anos ela não
consegue ter uma selecção mas tudo que
aconteceu
é pra oxum
o campo de refugiados das nações unidas
não parece muito o jogo voltou à luta
projeto fechou em braga é também da
violência um projeto sobre a evolução
multifacetada semana com seus projetos a
qualquer coisa como seis anos e só
terminei a dois anos atrás tem um
projeto sou um cidadão russo chamado
está bêbado imigrantes tentam imigrar
para a ucrânia numa fase inicial da sua
vida quando se envolveu como a sair em
grupos grito
naturalmente eu vou provar um caminho
das drogas é um caminho balcão
não era pra ter assegurado que todos
esses envolvimentos com vou perder
qualquer tipo que eu tenho qualquer
incentivo esportivo que o praticado
na verdade está mesmo tempo uma segunda
saída da imigração para inglaterra
também como foi observado em setembro de
2011 mãe já inscrito casa tentavam
emigrar pactual praia em braga não ser
um dos primeiros a sair naturalmente
antónio braga vai muito mal a gente
resolveu largar tudo isso tenha criado
um estilo de vida saudável e tentará
reunir com o grupo de saúde para poderem
fazer exercício físico
neste caso o olhar chama se tocado e
existe fisicamente para fazer nesses
campos técnico com o peso do próprio
corpo e concreto que acabou por juntar
os mais variados estratos sociais desde
professoras economistas a malta vai o
imigrante de tudo para conseguir criar
uma iniciativa feliz ação social e com
certeza estou sabendo se o corpo é mal
das coisas físico ferramenta é moldada
por seu filho e seu eu
michels nos insegura em estudos
filosóficos filmes da católica que
passou com distinção
vivemos um momento difícil com algumas
coisas mais complicadas acontece não
fizesse uma quebra na chamada luta para
conseguir o meu trabalho não esquecer
alguma emoção e não propriamente
tecnicamente perfeito está ficando que
está tecnicamente um esforço tendo
sempre como o trabalho seja o mais
cultura é possível uma das maiores
influências por exemplo o francês frank
tentou sendo que vocês que eu sabem
conceição sempre em momentos da rua
quando as condições são caetano é não
conseguiram desencantar duas funções de
médico para prática mortais uma sério
acidente em bolsa
a reunião permitiu cristalizado com se
ter a sua própria evolução testada
conseguiu em braga que a sua vida no
bairro e uma história da violência traz
ao brasil
antes disso vamos dizer eu comecei em
2006 depois de toda a minha história
naquela história do título da página
assim não é uma festa mas também como
sendo falta mesmo com uma uma afronta
quase faz uns queriam que eu fosse
realizada na força toda
será um bom salto vai ter que ligar
nisso para conseguir fazer uma coisa mas
não acho que não tem deslocava fazer
quando eu fui alta ea outra porque eu
sempre encontrar nessas histórias minhas
no qual eu queria passar o meu de
candidatura do meu pai que entrou no gol
da vitória que poderia imaginar o ritmo
frenético do meu irmão que também é
falso o visto é que acabei por criar o
vício no fotojornalismo tudo isto o vôo
ao fim de vários anos para fazer um
projeto
o projeto também mais uma vez as 11
crianças que votaria em uma instituição
que existem braga não cai porque é um
centro de atividades cat com 130
operacionais para malta com deficiência
mental em braga espera
é uma história que eu vou passar em
vídeo khan não só uma história de duas
crianças estão na instituição jovens e
os adultos foi o tamanho das pessoas
trabalha neste tipo de crime motors gm
tem colhido os dias para conseguir lidar
com essas situações
a narração é do futebol
o texto escrito por mariana - não está
em estado de choque
quem olha pra eu sempre fui à festa de
fim 9 pontos que devem estou prestes a
disputar as 500 vetá-los é outra
história e eu mec ninguém ainda
conseguiu cortar as palavras da sua veia
que usa companhia simples prospera ter
de mexer ferro quase eu gostava de
brincar neste momento esse é o seu olhar
nostálgico como um cientista conduta
desalmadamente de uma descoberta
importante para além da qualidade do
estado no entanto consciente de que não
terá oportunidade de ver uma história
reveladora da sua vida é impossível o
tesouro tinha mesmo fitas que se passa
ao lado de deus
os momentos de muito a comunicação com
quem encarna deficiência mental
estiveram tão escasso
todo ser humano eu voto na sua e mental
é algo latente e por isso aceitou uma
realidade assustadora por aí
o fuzileiro de risco o que já se tornou
a minha chance
quem sabe ainda na barriga da mãe
efe si/an ocidental neste sentido e
custoso percebe se que se o filho não é
igual aos outros mas por puxão aquilo
que conseguem quero fazer aprendi a
enfrentar nessa viagem completamente cop
tabu
a epe lembra do 4º e 6º estilos
à medida que esse perfil de conceito
corridas
está na hora veículo ou seria cuidado
para o habitual a enfiarem no refeitório
do mesmo perfil dos três mas só 15
sou um actor de facto há pouco melhor
dizendo uma vitória lá que é mais lógico
de todos os outros dois trocam mas
gostou que o prêmio do cobertor tapas
completamente e assim ficam deitados é
cuidado você gostar de cuidados para
chegar surdo como cuidar como chovido
mais estiloso bairro e esse filho tudo
nas suas vidas
é uma aventura tudo requerem este
esforço com cinqüenta cem o topo sebrae
és pontos anos ou doar feito torna
qualquer pequena nação na maior das
missões impossíveis
só quem convive com elas
só quem quer ver de perto a entender o
que é vida da sua total expectativa
espiada em todas as suas fases
o encantamento do rio o arco e colméia
da mais plena felicidade e mais isoladas
das regiões
conforta saber aos que o juninho de fora
com personagens de um filme sobre a
lista que estas pessoas não têm
sensibilidade ao frio e se o centro não
se queixa
existem em portugal o bastou a falta de
sensibilidade e conhecimento gerado pela
educação existentes sobre a estabilidade
que também ela faz parte da sociedade
não sabe o que é e nem sequer saber que
ela é nada comigo
vettel no entanto o país que seu bicho
mais cara que ia passar por utilizador
falha nas regras mais básicas
esse mesmo obrigados civismo inclusão
social
o dizer não ao preconceito claro que o
real evolução ficou cheia fingia eu não
sou nenhum estilo e novas formas de
aprendizagem e nestes casos
na oportunidade o furor sal é para os
projetos tinham simental silva era
comparar os juros que será cobrada a
sociedade local cronista visto uma
sociedade extremamente registradora com
plena liberdade e por arrasto o meu voto
crucial acima de tudo
apenas terminar e para escolher as luzes
já que o meu dia foi a contar as
histórias das pessoas ligadas a ela
contar as histórias das pessoas que faz
todos os dias para isso vai precisar
muito da fifa
o timbu na partida de volta
[Aplausos]